From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life. I'm Ike Sriskandarajah in for Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾（Ike Sriskandarajah），替艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）主持节目。
Pablo, does this feel like an Icarus story to you?
巴勃罗，这让你觉得像是个伊卡洛斯的故事吗？
Maybe, potentially.
也许，有可能。
What part?
哪一部分？
Well, Icarus dies. Not that part.
嗯，伊卡洛斯死了。不是那一部分。
This is Pablo Manriquez, and he recently survived his own personal Greek tragedy. He's a reporter in Washington, DC. I've known him for years. And this all began when a ripped-open package showed up on his front stoop.
这是巴勃罗·曼里克（Pablo Manriquez），他最近亲身经历了一场属于他自己的希腊悲剧。他是华盛顿特区的一名记者，我认识他很多年了。这一切始于他家门廊上出现的一个被撕开的包裹。
It's late winter, 2022. I find a box outside of my apartment. Inside is a canvas, the four primary colors, a paintbrush, and a palette. It just seemed like a sign.
那是2022年的冬末。我在公寓外发现了一个盒子。里面有一块画布、四种原色颜料、一把画笔和一个调色盘。这看起来就像是一个征兆。
Yeah. And that's like-- what's the sign?
是啊。那就像是——什么征兆呢？
It was just, I thought to myself, somebody painted every painting in the Capitol and the White House and the Department of Justice. All these agency buildings, they have oil paintings. And yet, in the 15 years that I've been in Washington, I've never met an oil painter.
我当时心想，有人为国会大厦、白宫和司法部画了所有的画。所有这些机构大楼里都有油画。然而，在我住在华盛顿的15年里，我从未见过一位油画家。
He had this light bulb moment. That could be him.
他灵光一现。那个人可以是自己。
It wasn't the first time he decided to become a new Pablo. When we first met, he was doing PR work. But he decided he wanted to be a reporter no matter what. So at 37, he moved into a flophouse and began freelancing for small publications. And now he spends his days chasing down politicians in the halls of Congress. He made it happen. So with these art supplies, he began to imagine this other life for himself. And he made a Pablo kind of plan.
这并不是他第一次决定成为一个新的巴勃罗。我们刚认识时，他在做公关工作。但他下定决心无论如何都要成为一名记者。所以37岁那年，他搬进了一家廉价旅馆，开始为小刊物做自由撰稿人。现在，他每天都在国会大厅里追逐政客。他成功了。所以有了这些艺术用品，他开始为自己构想另一种生活。他制定了一个“巴勃罗式”的计划。
So I was like, if I become an oil painter, I would basically be the only oil painter I know and, in some sense, have a monopoly on oil painting in Washington. You know what I mean? If you want an oil painting, especially a portrait, you have to come to me.
所以我当时想，如果我成为一名油画家，我基本上就是我所认识的唯一一名油画家，在某种意义上，垄断了华盛顿的油画业务。你明白我的意思吗？如果你想要一幅油画，尤其是肖像画，你就得来找我。
What Pablo lacks in skill and experience he compensates for with heat-seeking opportunism and blinding self-confidence. It can rub people the wrong way, but I appreciate the hustle.
巴勃罗在技巧和经验上的欠缺，用他那种追逐机会的劲头和盲目的自信弥补了。这可能会让人不舒服，但我很欣赏这种拼劲。
Pablo, it's so funny to me that you're trying to pick one career in-- I can say it --a dying industry by supplementing your income with another dying industry.
巴勃罗，我觉得很有趣的是，你试图在一个——我可以直说——夕阳行业里选择一个职业，同时还用另一个夕阳行业来增加收入。
Reporting, an artist, it's like the two poorest. It didn't make any sense to a lot of people.
报道，艺术家，这就像是两个最贫穷的行业。这对很多人来说都毫无意义。
But it made sense to Pablo. Pablo looked down at the new tools in his hands and then tilted his head skyward. Even as Icarus did before him, he saw a way to soar where no mortal had dared to soar. Our show today, myths in real life. What happened next to Pablo, and other daring actions by mortals challenging their small lives. And a cameo by a real life god because the gods get mad if you don't include them, and I'm too busy to get smote. Not today, Hades. Stay with us.
但这对巴勃罗来说是有意义的。巴勃罗低头看着手中新的工具，然后抬头望向天空。正如伊卡洛斯当年所做的那样，他看到了一条凡人从未敢尝试的翱翔之路。我们今天的节目，现实生活中的神话。接下来巴勃罗发生了什么，以及凡人们挑战平凡生活的其他大胆举动。还有一个真实神灵的客串，因为如果你不把他们包括在内，神灵会生气的，而且我太忙了，没空被雷劈。今天不行，哈迪斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act 1, Icarus. So Pablo Manriquez, in Washington, DC, had received these art supplies, perhaps discarded by an Amazon package thief, or perhaps a gift from the gods. And he figured, there's all these big egos in town who would love to be memorialized in oil portraits. Well, I could do that for them. Even though Pablo himself had never painted a portrait in his life, or painted anything for that matter.
这里是《美国生活》，第一幕，伊卡洛斯。巴勃罗·曼里克在华盛顿特区收到了这些艺术用品，也许是被亚马逊包裹窃贼丢弃的，又或者是神灵赐予的礼物。他想，城里有这么多大人物，他们肯定很乐意被画成油画肖像。好吧，我可以为他们做这件事。尽管巴勃罗本人从未画过肖像，或者说，他从未画过任何东西。
I had a clear vision in mind of what I needed to do. I needed to learn how to paint a face.
我心中有一个清晰的愿景，知道自己需要做什么。我需要学会如何画人脸。
Politicians have them. We can't sell a portrait without one. Pablo finds a YouTube channel called Paint Coach. It has a 10-minute crash course. He follows along. He starts moving paint around on the canvas, and he's hooked. In his head, he's already competing with the legends who are hanging on walls around town. He just needs a first subject to paint. It's got to be someone widely recognizable, someone distinct and iconic. So he picks Mitch McConnell.
政客们都有脸。没有脸，我们就卖不出肖像画。巴勃罗找到了一个叫“绘画教练”（Paint Coach）的YouTube频道。它有一个10分钟的速成课程。他跟着练习。他开始在画布上涂抹颜料，然后就上瘾了。在他脑海里，他已经在和城里墙上挂着的那些传奇人物竞争了。他只需要第一个绘画对象。必须是一个广为人知、独特且具有标志性的人物。所以他选择了米奇·麦康奈尔（Mitch McConnell）。
He's always had super, super loyal staffers. I mean, I imagine he's-- according to his book, The Long Game, he's run out all his enemies and installed all of his friends. So I was hoping to find Mitch McConnell fans to buy Mitch McConnell paintings. Another thing I did, I looked up on Etsy, I looked up on the typical places where you would go to buy an oil painting, and I couldn't find any oil paintings of Mitch McConnell. If I painted five paintings of Mitch McConnell in a week, I had the only five paintings of Mitch McConnell in existence for sale. Right?
他一直有超级、超级忠诚的幕僚。我的意思是，据他的书《长远博弈》（The Long Game）所述，他赶走了所有的敌人，安插了自己的朋友。所以我希望能找到米奇·麦康奈尔的粉丝来购买米奇·麦康奈尔的画作。我还做了另一件事，我在Etsy上搜索，查看了通常购买油画的地方，但我找不到任何米奇·麦康奈尔的油画。如果我一周画五幅米奇·麦康奈尔的画，那我就是市面上仅有这五幅米奇·麦康奈尔画作的人。对吧？
After a few tries, he gets one that looks enough like Mitch McConnell. So he posts a few pictures of his progress, and someone notices. The next day--
尝试了几次之后，他画出了一幅足够像米奇·麦康奈尔的作品。于是他在网上发布了一些绘画进度照片，有人注意到了。第二天——
I was walking through the Senate, and one of his aides kind of came out of the woodwork and was just like, hey, man, these paintings of our boss that you're posting on Instagram are really cool, but could you maybe paint him smiling? I was just like, boom. Hell yeah, I can paint him smiling. I can paint him smiling all day long.
我正走在参议院里，他的一位助手不知从哪冒出来，说道：“嘿，哥们，你在Instagram上发的那些我们老板的画真的很酷，但你能把他画得微笑一点吗？”我当时就觉得，太棒了。当然可以，我可以把他画得微笑。我可以画他笑一整天。
Have you ever had a picture in your office of your boss smiling at you? If you have, you might be living in a country where the name "leader" is preceded by "great" or "supreme." I'd like to take this moment to say, I am grateful to work here at This American Life, where the company reimburses half the cost of the smiling portrait of Ira that we are forced to hang in our offices.
你的办公室里有没有一张老板对你微笑的照片？如果有，你可能生活在一个“领袖”前面带有“伟大”或“最高”头衔的国家。我想借此机会说，我很感激能在《美国生活》工作，公司报销了我们被迫挂在办公室里的艾拉微笑肖像画的一半费用。
Pablo delivers his first smiling Senator to Mitch McConnell's staffer. And then he gets a request for another, and another. He's 18 Mitch McConnells deep before he stops to catch his breath.
巴勃罗把他的第一个微笑参议员交给了麦康奈尔的助手。然后他得到了第二份请求，接着是第三份。在停下来喘口气之前，他已经画了18个米奇·麦康奈尔了。
Were those Mitch McConnells-- in your opinion, were they good?
在你看，那些米奇·麦康奈尔的画好吗？
I can't think of a single Mitch McConnell I ever did that was good.
我画的每一个米奇·麦康奈尔，我都想不出哪一个称得上好。
But they were good enough. He sold the first small one for $25, the next one for $50. Eventually, he settled on $500 for 24-by-36-inch paintings. Pablo is becoming a prolific painter. He paints Nancy Pelosi, Ilhan Omar, other politicians. He takes a commission for a lobbyist's dog. Just by his own force of personality, he's making it happen.
但它们足够好了。他以25美元卖出了第一幅小的，接着以50美元卖出了下一幅。最终，他把24乘36英寸的画定在了500美元。巴勃罗正在成为一名多产的画家。他画南希·佩洛西（Nancy Pelosi）、伊尔汗·奥马尔（Ilhan Omar）和其他政客。他还接受了一位说客给狗画肖像的委托。仅仅凭他个人的性格魅力，他做到了。
At the State of the Union, Pablo set up an easel in Statuary Hall. That's overlooking where all the members of Congress and the Supreme Court justices pass through. And Pablo, in his white painter's coat with headphones on, he captured the scene on canvas live.
在国情咨文演讲期间，巴勃罗在雕像大厅搭起了一个画架。那里正对着所有国会议员和最高法院大法官经过的地方。巴勃罗穿着他那件白色画家外套，戴着耳机，现场捕捉着画面。
This is something that is a side project of yours?
这是你的副业吗？
C-span interviewed him as he painted. And then late last year, in December, he got a phone call from a friend's number, someone who used to be a policy advisor in the executive branch.
当他在作画时，C-SPAN采访了他。去年年底，12月，他接到了一个朋友号码打来的电话，对方曾是行政部门的一名政策顾问。
I picked up. And I was just like, hey, man, what do you need? I'm kind of busy. I hear on the other end of the line, hey, Pablo, you're a great artist. This is Joe Biden. I'm like, bull-[BLEEP], man. Very funny, right? He's like, no, no, no, I'm serious. Hey, Jill, put it on FaceTime. And bloop, bloop bloop. The FaceTime noise plays. And I'm looking at Dr. Jill Biden.
我接了电话，我说：“嘿，伙计，有什么事吗？我很忙。”我听到电话那头说：“嘿，巴勃罗，你是一位伟大的艺术家。我是乔·拜登（Joe Biden）。”我回答：“胡扯，伙计。真好笑，对吧？”他说：“不，不，不，我是认真的。嘿，吉尔（Jill），开启FaceTime。”然后，“嘟，嘟，嘟”，FaceTime的声音响起。我看到了吉尔·拜登博士。
And I'm like, oh my God. I'm so sorry, ma'am. I'm so sorry for cursing. I did not mean to say BS in front of you. Yeah, this is real. And she hands the phone back over to Joe Biden. And he was just like, you're a really good artist. This is a really great portrait of Jill and me.
我当时说：“天哪。真的很抱歉，夫人。我很抱歉刚才骂了脏话。我没想在您面前说胡扯。是的，这是真的。”她把手机递回给乔·拜登。他只是说：“你真的是个很棒的艺术家。这是一幅我和吉尔的非常棒的肖像画。”
If you've been wondering what Joe Biden's been up to since leaving office, well, mystery solved.
如果你一直想知道乔·拜登离任后在忙些什么，好吧，谜底解开了。
He knew the photo that it came from. It was from the 1970s, when they first met. So it was an oil painting of them when they were young. And I was on FaceTime with the president. There were probably 25 reporters in the press gallery filing their stories. And pretty soon, they were all gathered around me. And we were all talking to Joe Biden-- The Washington Post, the AP, the Bloomberg, HuffPost, were all talking-- and Fox News, Daily Caller, we're all looking into the camera and talking to Joe Biden. And he's just telling everybody how bomb my painting is. I was like, that was awesome. That was awesome.
他认出了照片的来源。那是20世纪70年代，他们刚认识的时候。所以这是一幅他们年轻时的油画。我当时正在和总统FaceTime。新闻发布室里可能有25名记者在写稿。很快，他们都围在了我身边。我们都在和乔·拜登交谈——《华盛顿邮报》、美联社、彭博社、赫芬顿邮报都在说话——福克斯新闻、每日传讯（Daily Caller）都在看镜头和乔·拜登交谈。他一直在告诉所有人我的画有多棒。我当时想，太棒了，这真是太棒了。
This is the part of the story when Icarus, with wings cobbled together with wax and feathers, experiences the miracle of flight. Hey, I can see my Minotaur from here. Well, for many mortals, this level of success is thrilling and enough. But not for Pablo. Pablo has a bigger goal. He wants one of his paintings officially hung in the Capitol, approved by a committee and hung by an entity known as the architect of the Capitol, the only people allowed to drive a nail in the wall. Pablo wants to be immortalized in these halls of power.
这就是故事中，伊卡洛斯用蜡和羽毛拼凑出的翅膀，体验飞行奇迹的那一部分。嘿，从这儿能看到我的弥诺陶洛斯。好吧，对许多凡人来说，这种程度的成功是令人兴奋且满足的。但对巴勃罗来说不然。巴勃罗有更大的目标。他希望自己的画能被正式挂在国会大厦里，经过委员会批准，由所谓的“国会大厦建筑师”（Architect of the Capitol）挂上，因为只有这些人被允许在墙上钉钉子。巴勃罗想要在这些权力的殿堂中流芳百世。
I have no legacy. Like, you know what I mean? And while no one might remember any story I write ever, right, the painting will be there for centuries. Centuries, if it's on the wall.
我没有什么遗产。你知道我的意思吗？虽然可能没人会记得我写的任何故事，但画作会在那里保存几个世纪。几个世纪，只要它挂在墙上。
Maybe you've been wondering this whole time, what do these paintings look like? So to be totally honest, Pablo has improved a lot. But he's doing work that looks like it's made by a talented art student, maybe a folk artist. The colors are pleasing. You can always tell who it is he's painting. But it's not, you know, John Trumbull's painting of the founders signing the Declaration of Independence, or any of the other museum grade paintings hanging in the Capitol rotunda.
也许你一直很好奇，这些画到底长什么样？老实说，巴勃罗进步了很多。但他画出来的作品看起来就像是一个有才华的艺术系学生，或者民间艺人画的。颜色令人愉悦。你总是能认出他画的是谁。但它并不是约翰·特朗布尔（John Trumbull）画的那些签署《独立宣言》的开国元勋，也不是国会大厦圆顶大厅里挂着的那些博物馆级的画作。
Of course, that does not stop Pablo, and a couple of months ago, he saw a way to make his dream happen. In February, the House voted to rename the press gallery after Frederick Douglass, who, among many other things, was also the first Black reporter to cover the Capitol. There was going to be a renaming ceremony and press conference. Well, it just so happened that Pablo had made a portrait of Frederick Douglass. It had been leaning against the wall in the press gallery for the last two years. So Pablo quickly hatched a plan. He's going to grab his painting, sneak his painting into the room where the ceremony is going to take place, and slip it onto a table where everyone can see it.
当然，这并没有阻止巴勃罗。几个月前，他找到了实现梦想的方法。二月份，众议院投票决定将新闻发布室以弗雷德里克·道格拉斯（Frederick Douglass）的名字命名，他不仅是废奴主义者，还是报道国会大厦的第一位黑人记者。当时要举行更名仪式和新闻发布会。恰好巴勃罗画了一幅弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的肖像。这幅画已经在新闻发布室的墙边靠了两年了。于是巴勃罗迅速制定了一个计划。他要带上他的画，悄悄溜进举行仪式的房间，把它塞到一张桌子上，让大家都能看到。
I scoped out the room. I was like, oh, there are artifacts about Frederick Douglass here. Like, there was this ledger of sales and stuff like that under glass. I was like, I'm going to go grab my painting and put it on the table. And I did. It's like a pop art portrait of Frederick Douglass with a yellow background, like a distinct yellow background.
我查看了房间。我心想，哦，这里有关于弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的文物。比如，玻璃柜下有销售账目之类的东西。我心想，我要去把我的画拿过来，放在桌子上。我真的这么做了。那是一幅带有黄色背景的波普艺术风格的弗雷德里克·道格拉斯肖像。
It's a pretty big canvas, nearly life-sized. And it sticks out compared to, say, the items on loan from the Library of Congress. But nobody says anything. Then the VIPs come in. There's the Speaker of the House, Mike Johnson, Representative Byron Donalds, the bill's sponsor. And there's even a living descendant of Frederick Douglass. Traditionally, at a press conference like this, the press are there to cover the event, not insert themselves into it. But Pablo is Pablo.
画布相当大，几乎是真人的大小。与国会图书馆借出的物品相比，它显得很突兀。但没人说什么。接着贵宾们进来了。有众议院议长迈克·约翰逊（Mike Johnson），该法案的提案人拜伦·唐纳兹（Byron Donalds）众议员。甚至还有一位弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的在世后代。传统上，在这样的新闻发布会上，媒体是来报道事件的，而不是参与其中。但巴勃罗就是巴勃罗。
And when Mike Johnson came in, I showed it to him. I showed it to Byron Donalds. He's like, oh, yeah, there. And that's when Frederick Douglass's grandson was like, that's great, that's great.
当迈克·约翰逊进来时，我把它展示给他看。我把它展示给拜伦·唐纳兹看。他说：“哦，是的，在那里。”就在那时，弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的孙子说：“那太棒了，太棒了。”
Probably not grandson.
可能不是孙子。
And then he kept walking. I was like, OK, so Frederick Douglass's grandson is cool with this. Byron Donalds is cool with this. Speaker Johnson is cool with this.
然后他继续往前走。我心想，好吧，所以弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的孙子觉得没问题。拜伦·唐纳兹觉得没问题。议长约翰逊也觉得没问题。
He gets a selfie with the lawmakers and his painting.
他和议员们以及他的画一起自拍了一张。
Everybody loves the painting. So let's get it hung on the wall officially.
每个人都喜欢这幅画。所以让我们把它正式挂在墙上吧。
To do that, Pablo just needs the permission of something called the Standing Committee of Correspondents. These are a group of Pablo's own peers, other working journalists. So he writes them a letter, donating his painting to the committee and asking that they hang it in the newly-named Frederick Douglass Press Gallery. A couple weeks later, the Standing Committee of Correspondents meet. The first new business on the agenda that day is to take a vote regarding artwork.
要做到这一点，巴勃罗只需要获得“常设记者委员会”（Standing Committee of Correspondents）的许可。这是一群巴勃罗的同僚，其他在职记者。所以他写了一封信给他们，捐赠这幅画，并请求将其挂在以弗雷德里克·道格拉斯命名的新闻发布室里。几周后，常设记者委员会召开了会议。那天议程上的第一项新业务就是对艺术品进行投票。
And they voted no. They said no. I was just like, oh. I still don't know exactly why.
结果他们投票否决了。他们拒绝了。我当时想，噢。我至今不知道具体原因。
Did you ask any of them?
你问过他们中的任何一个吗？
No.
没有。
Pablo was not discouraged by this decision. Of course he wasn't. He was like, well, if they don't like this Frederick Douglass, I'm going to make them a much bigger Frederick Douglass. And if they don't like that, I'll paint a smaller one. And I'll keep painting and donating Frederick Douglasses until the dam breaks and they all go up. I thought that sounded like a lot of work, at least more than asking them why they said no.
巴勃罗并没有因为这个决定而气馁。他当然不会。他想：“好吧，如果他们不喜欢这幅弗雷德里克·道格拉斯，我就给他们画一幅更大的。如果他们还是不喜欢，我就再画一幅更小的。我会一直画下去，不断捐赠弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的画像，直到大坝决堤，让它们全部挂上去。”我觉得这听起来工作量很大，至少比问他们为什么拒绝要辛苦得多。
So I reached out and got hold of the meeting minutes. The problem was not about the size or the quality or anything like that. The problem was that Pablo had crossed a line.
于是我联系并获取了会议记录。问题根本不在于尺寸、质量或任何类似的事情。问题在于巴勃罗越界了。
The thing that they voted on wasn't at all about your painting, but a broad rule that would apply to all future situations.
他们投票决定的事情根本不是关于你的画，而是一项适用于所有未来情况的广泛规则。
What was the rule, don't bring a painting?
规则是什么，不能带画进来？
No, it's not, don't bring a painting. Is that no credentialed reporter will be able to make artwork that hangs on the walls of the Capitol. Is this the first time you're hearing that?
不，不是不能带画进来。而是没有认证的记者可以创作挂在国会大厦墙上的艺术品。这是你第一次听到这个消息吗？
Yeah. And that's written down?
是的。这是写下来的吗？
Yeah. It was a 4-to-1 vote. And how does that make you feel?
是的。那是4对1的投票结果。这让你感觉如何？
Kind of sad.
有点难过。
According to a statement from the Standing Committee, they were worried about what precedent it would set, what conflicts of interests hanging his painting could cause. And Pablo hadn't gotten permission from the event organizers to put his painting into their event.
根据常设委员会的一份声明，他们担心这会开创什么样的先例，挂上他的画会引起什么样的利益冲突。而且巴勃罗在把画放入活动现场前，并没有获得活动组织者的许可。
Icarus, son of Daedalus, soaring over the Isle, was enthralled by his own new ability. He couldn't help wanting to go higher. Pablo, son of Luis, didn't want to only stay in the back of the press conference with the other scribes. Couldn't this event to honor Frederick Douglass also honor Pablo, too? Maybe if he'd asked permission, gone through channels, this all might have worked out differently. I floated that idea by Pablo.
伊卡洛斯，代达罗斯之子，翱翔在岛屿上空，被自己新获得的能力所吸引。他忍不住想要飞得更高。路易斯之子巴勃罗，不想仅仅和其他写稿人一起待在新闻发布会的后面。这个纪念弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的活动难道不能也纪念一下巴勃罗吗？也许如果他请求许可，走正规程序，这一切可能会有不同的结果。我把这个想法提给了巴勃罗。
Was there another way to do it? Yeah. But I still think this was the best way.
还有其他办法吗？有。但我仍然认为这是最好的办法。
Even when you're thinking about it now, reflecting on it?
即使当你现在回想起来的时候？
Yeah, because humility could not possibly have created that scenario to begin with. At every point along the way, it was driven by ego.
是的，因为谦逊不可能从一开始就创造出那种场景。在这一路上的每一个点，都是由自我驱动的。
A lot of it was ego.
其中很大一部分是自我。
Maybe like 91%, 92%. I definitely wake up every morning excited to be Pablo Manriquez.
也许是91%或92%吧。我每天醒来确实都很兴奋能成为巴勃罗·曼里克。
Ego-- it's what makes you pick up a box of stolen art supplies and think, without any experience, I will be a transformational force in the US Capitol. But it's also ego that propels you to the front of a press conference, with your painting under your arm, and sends you crashing back to Earth. The Potomac is lousy with wax and feathers.
自我——这让你拿起一盒被盗的艺术用品，心想：没有任何经验，我将成为美国国会大厦的一股变革力量。但同样是自我，推动你带着画走到了新闻发布会的最前沿，然后让你狠狠地摔回地面。波托马克河到处都是蜡和羽毛。
A couple hours after we talk, Pablo sends me a note. He's back in the Capitol. He says, for the first time, he feels small in this place that once made him feel big. The next day, he sends me another note. He sounds like himself again. He figured it out. He's launching his campaign to run for Standing Committee.
我们在谈话几小时后，巴勃罗给我发了一条信息。他回到了国会大厦。他说，这是他第一次在这个曾经让他感到伟大的地方感到渺小。第二天，他又给我发了一条信息。他又变回了那个他自己。他想通了。他要发起竞选活动，去争取常设委员会的席位。
But luckily, I'm not eligible to run for the Standing Committee for at least another year, if not two. So I decided that, while I can't be on the ballot until probably 2028, I am going to start campaigning on Monday. So I registered the domain dailypressgallery.com, and I started writing an agenda. Part of my agenda is, of course, to repeal the prohibition that they put on journalist art in the Capitol.
但幸运的是，我至少还要再等一年，如果不是两年，才有资格竞选常设委员会。所以我决定，虽然我可能要到2028年才能出现在选票上，但我周一就要开始竞选活动了。所以我注册了域名dailypressgallery.com，并开始撰写一份议程。我的议程的一部分，当然是废除他们对记者在国会大厦创作艺术品的禁令。
You never hear about Icarus the next day. Did you know he just made some small adjustments to his wings and headed right back for the sun?
你从没听说过伊卡洛斯第二天怎么样了。你知道他只是对翅膀做了一些微调，就立刻又朝太阳飞去了吗？
If you want to see Pablo's paintings or follow his campaign for Standing Committee, he's at Pablo.Manriquez on Instagram.
如果你想看巴勃罗的画或者关注他竞选常设委员会，请访问Instagram上的Pablo.Manriquez。
That brings us to act two, Cerberus.
这把我们带到了第二幕，刻耳柏洛斯。
You know how in Greek mythology there's Hades, where everyone goes when they die? You gotta cross the River Styx to get there. And then there's this gate with this three-headed dog, Cerberus. He's guarding the entrance, and he's supposed to make sure only actually dead people enter. This story is about a real person in America who stood at those very gates, which is not the easiest job, it turns out. At least not right now. Nadia Reiman talked to him about it.
你知道希腊神话中有一个哈迪斯（冥界），每个人死后都会去那里吗？你得穿过冥河才能到达那里。那里有一个守着大门的三头狗，刻耳柏洛斯。它负责把守入口，确保只有真正的死者才能进入。这个故事是关于一个在美国的真实人物，他站在了那扇大门前，事实证明，那不是一份容易的工作。至少现在不是。纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）和他聊了聊这件事。
When Jeremiah Schofield started working at the Social Security Administration, the SSA, the first thing his boss said to him was, if you're looking up your ex's records, your own records, or looking up someone famous, don't. We will know. Then they made him read Title V of the US Code Section 552a, The Privacy Act, the actual legal text of it. That's how much they wanted to drive the point home.
当杰里迈亚·斯科菲尔德（Jeremiah Schofield）开始在社会保障局（SSA）工作时，他老板对他说的第一句话就是：“如果你想查询你前任的记录、你自己的记录，或者查询名人的记录，千万别这么做。我们会知道的。”然后他们让他阅读了美国法典第5编第552a条《隐私法》的实际法律文本。他们就是这样极力想把这一重点灌输给他。
The Social Security Administration is the caretaker of these truly massive databases of personal information. They use it to send Social Security checks, disability payments. And in order to do that accurately, given how there's over 300 million of us, they keep master files. Jeremiah says they have all sorts of information from all sorts of moments in your life-- where you were born, your Social Security number, your mom's maiden name, your citizenship status, all of it stored in giant files.
社会保障局是这些真正庞大的个人信息数据库的保管者。他们用它来发送社会保障支票和残疾赔偿金。为了准确地做到这一点，考虑到我们有超过3亿人口，他们保留了主文件。杰里迈亚说，他们拥有你生命中各个时刻的各种信息——你的出生地、社会保障号码、你母亲的婚前姓氏、你的公民身份，所有这些都存储在巨大的文件中。
Your master earnings files will show every job that you ever worked at. And it would show how much money you made at all of those different jobs.
你的收入主文件会显示你曾经工作过的每一份工作。它会显示你在所有这些不同工作中赚了多少钱。
Every job people have had?
人们做过的每一份工作吗？
Yep. And then you have the disability control file, which actually gets into disability-related information.
是的。然后你还有残疾控制文件，它实际上涉及与残疾相关的信息。
That's for people who collect disability.
那是给领取残疾补助金的人用的。
Things like what your disability-- there's listings of codes for if you have cancer or if you have some other type of ailment. And so it would have all of that information in it. So it's very sensitive information. At Social Security, we've always treated those records as though they're things that they cannot be let out to anybody.
像你的残疾情况之类的——如果你患有癌症或有其他类型的疾病，文件里会有代码列表。所以它会拥有所有这些信息。这是非常敏感的信息。在社会保障局，我们一直把这些记录视为绝不能泄露给任何人的东西。
Like, they contain people's whole lives, basically.
就像是，它们基本上包含了人们的整个人生。
That's right. Very sensitive moments in their lives.
没错。他们生活中非常敏感的时刻。
The point of the many rules governing these lists and files is not just privacy, though. It's about making sure all this information is used only for its intended purpose, by the book. And Jeremiah, from what I can tell, is a by-the-book kind of guy.
但管理这些列表和文件的众多规则的目的不仅是隐私。而是确保所有这些信息仅按照规定用于其预定目的。据我所知，杰里迈亚是一个按部就班的人。
There's one database with arguably more power than the others and a name to match. It's called the Death Master File. It's a master list of all the dead. Well, all the deaths recorded since the dawn of Social Security.
有一个数据库的权力和影响力堪称之最，名字也相当贴切。它叫“死亡主文件”（Death Master File）。它是所有死者的主列表。好吧，是自社会保障局成立以来记录的所有死亡人数。
It has millions and millions of names. People get added to it when they die, their name and their date of death. If you get accidentally added to it when you are not dead, it can mess up your Social Security payments, sure, but also your bank accounts, all kinds of things. So Jeremiah and everyone treated this one with extreme care.
它有数百万个名字。人们死后会被添加到其中，包括他们的名字和死亡日期。如果你在没死的时候被意外添加进去，这会扰乱你的社会保障金，当然，还有你的银行账户，以及各种各样的事情。所以杰里迈亚和每个人都极度谨慎地处理这个文件。
And one day, Jeremiah says, he was summoned to a meeting. And the first thing he sees when he enters the meeting room, handwritten on all these whiteboards, are the names of all these databases, including the Death Master File.
杰里迈亚说，有一天，他被召集去开会。当他进入会议室时，他看到的第一件事就是手写在所有白板上的所有数据库名称，包括死亡主文件。
The whole meeting was kind of strange, actually. Jeremiah was a boss. At this point, he had been there 25 years, his first proper adult job. So he'd been to a lot of meetings, but none like this. It was not put on the official calendar, and the whole thing was very secretive. It was in a half-used office building. There was a guard in the hallway, almost like a bouncer. And in the room, three people with non-government laptops.
整个会议相当奇怪，真的。杰里迈亚是一位主管。此时他已经在那里工作了25年，这是他第一份正儿八经的成年工作。所以他参加过很多会议，但从来没有像这次这样的。它没有被列在官方日程表上，整件事非常神秘。它在一栋半闲置的办公大楼里。走廊里有个警卫，就像个保镖。房间里有三个带着非政府笔记本电脑的人。
This was February of last year. And these guys, they worked for DOGE, so-called Department of Government Efficiency, headed by Elon Musk. In the meeting, Jeremiah makes some proposals, some ways Social Security can be more efficient, better IT to update these lists quicker. But he's almost instantly interrupted by one of the DOGE guys, Antonio Gracias, a venture capitalist, now Team Elon.
那是去年二月。这些人是为DOGE工作的，也就是所谓的“政府效率部”，由埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）领导。在会上，杰里迈亚提出了一些建议，关于社会保障局如何提高效率、利用更好的IT系统更快地更新这些名单的方法。但他几乎立刻被其中一个DOGE成员、风险投资家、现在的埃隆团队成员安东尼奥·格拉西亚斯（Antonio Gracias）打断了。
And within two minutes, Mr. Gracias had shut down the conversation and said, we're here to talk about Social Security fraud. And we're looking for a big win. And I said, well, a big win? I mean, I have millions of dollars in potential savings by doing these new IT systems. And he said he was only willing to go to the president with a big win of-- he said $50 billion savings.
在两分钟内，格拉西亚斯先生终止了谈话，说道：“我们是来讨论社会保障欺诈的。我们正在寻找一个重大的胜利。”我说：“好吧，重大的胜利？我的意思是，通过执行这些新的IT系统，我可以节省数百万美元的资金。”他说他只愿意带着一个“重大胜利”去找总统，他说是节省500亿美元。
What did you say?
你是怎么说的？
Well, what I said was that I don't think you're going to find $50 billion in fraud.
我当时说的是，我不认为你们能在欺诈中找到500亿美元。
Around this time, Elon Musk announced on X that they might have found some fraud. The fraud was related to the Death Master File. Musk was pointing to a problem with it, namely that there were people who were clearly dead who were not in it, people who seem to be 150 years old, according to other Social Security databases. He posted, quote, "Maybe Twilight is real and there are a lot of vampires collecting Social Security." He even brought it up in the Oval Office with President Trump, before the cameras.
大约在这个时候，埃隆·马斯克在X上宣布他们可能发现了一些欺诈行为。欺诈与死亡主文件有关。马斯克指出了一个问题，即名单中有一些人明显已经死了却不在名单里，有些人根据其他社会保障数据库显示似乎已经150岁了。他发帖称：“也许《暮光之城》是真的，有很多吸血鬼在领取社会保障金。”甚至在摄像机前，在椭圆形办公室与特朗普总统讨论过这个问题。
Now, do you know anyone who's 150? I don't. OK? They should be on the Guinness Book of World Records. They're missing out.
现在，你认识任何150岁的人吗？我不认识。好了吗？他们应该被列入吉尼斯世界纪录。他们错过了。
Jeremiah saw all this.
杰里迈亚看到了这一切。
So in layman's terms, I was pissed off that our leaders in the country were saying this. And it was infuriating.
所以用外行话来说，我们的国家领导人说出这种话让我很生气。这真是令人愤怒。
Jeremiah was pissed off because, in layman's terms, [BLEEP]'s complicated. It's true that there were some people who appeared to be 150 not marked as dead, but the Social Security Administration knew that already. And they knew why. Sometimes the death of a person born in 1875 or whatever didn't get reported to the SSA. And without an official death date, that person didn't go on the Death Master File.
杰里迈亚很生气，因为用外行话来说，这简直太复杂了。有些人确实看起来有150岁且没有被标记为死亡，这一点是真的，但社会保障局早就知道了。而且他们知道原因。有时，一个1875年或类似年份出生的人死亡时，并没有上报给社会保障局。如果没有正式的死亡日期，那个人就不会出现在死亡主文件里。
Regardless, there was a whole system in place to make sure Social Security payments did not go out to these people. Because when someone is over 100, the Social Security Administration actually contacts them to make sure they're still alive.
无论如何，确实有一套完整的系统来确保社会保障金不会发放给这些人。因为当某人超过100岁时，社会保障局实际上会联系他们以确认他们是否仍然活着。
And so we have different groupings of technicians within the agency that literally make phone calls to these folks, and in some cases go to people's houses just to make sure-- hey, Jeremiah is over 100 years old. Let's make sure that he's still living and that he's receiving the benefits that he needs to.
所以我们在机构内有不同分组的技术人员，他们确实会给这些人打电话，在某些情况下还会去人们的家里确认——“嘿，杰里迈亚已经100多岁了。让我们确认他是否还活着，是否正在领取他需要的福利。”
He says some of these 100-plus year olds are happy to have a visitor. Others are like, go away, of course I'm alive. And if there's any fraud, anyone taking in a paycheck for a dead relative, the SSA would catch it. Plus, the SSA had already tried to clean up the Death Master File, specifically chasing down death dates for these 150-plus year olds. But it took a lot of time and resources, and it didn't save the government any money, because it's not like the SSA had been sending checks to these dead people. So the opposite of efficiency.
他说，其中一些100多岁的老人很高兴有人来看望他们。其他人则会说：“走开，我当然还活着。”如果有任何欺诈行为，有人为已故亲属代领工资，社会保障局都会发现。此外，社会保障局已经尝试清理死亡主文件，专门追查这些150多岁的老人的死亡日期。但这耗费了大量的时间和资源，并没有为政府省下一分钱，因为社会保障局根本就没有给这些死人发过支票。所以这与效率恰恰相反。
But DOGE still pressed on. They wanted Jeremiah's team to mark these apparent 150-year-olds as dead and mark them now. Just populate the sensitive list with random death dates, which was totally unheard of. And it made Jeremiah a little nervous It seemed like a bad precedent because, remember, if you make a mistake in the Death Master File, say, mark someone dead who isn't, it's not just their Social Security that gets shut off. Anything tied to their Social Security number is now bricked.
但DOGE仍然坚持这样做。他们想让杰里迈亚的团队把这些看似150岁的老人标记为死亡，而且要现在就标记。仅仅在敏感名单上随意填上死亡日期，这是完全闻所未闻的。这让杰里迈亚有点紧张。这似乎是个糟糕的先例，因为请记住，如果你在死亡主文件中犯了错误，比如把一个还活着的人标记为死亡，那么不仅仅是他们的社会保障金会被停掉。任何与他们社会保障号码相关的东西现在都彻底报废了。
The person finds out, often in pretty dramatic fashion, that they have been killed off by accident. Like, they go to the grocery store, they try to pay with their credit card, and it doesn't work. Then they try to pay with another credit card. Same thing. So they go home and call the bank. And they're like, what's going on?
当事人发现时，往往是以相当戏剧性的方式，发现自己被意外弄死了。就像，他们去杂货店，试图用信用卡支付，结果不行。然后他们尝试用另一张信用卡。还是一样。于是他们回家给银行打电话。他们问：“发生了什么？”
And they would have been directed to go to Social Security to fix the problem.
他们会被指引去社会保障局解决这个问题。
Could they have access to their money in their bank accounts or no?
他们能动用银行账户里的钱吗？
The bank accounts would have been frozen.
银行账户会被冻结。
Oh my God. So it's not even that they can't use credit cards. They can't take money that they have in the bank out of the bank at all.
天哪。所以不仅仅是他们不能使用信用卡。他们根本无法从银行取出哪怕一点钱。
That's right. Everything just stops because everybody thinks that the person is deceased.
没错。一切都停止了，因为每个人都认为那个人已经去世了。
It's a mess. And now here was DOGE, insisting Jeremiah's team marked these 150-plus year olds as dead. Jeremiah was like, OK, I know we don't have physical proof, but if the date of birth is right, logic says these people are for sure dead. So it didn't seem that risky.
这简直是一团糟。现在DOGE坚持要求杰里迈亚的团队把这些150多岁的老人标记为死亡。杰里迈亚当时想，好吧，我知道我们没有实际证据，但如果出生日期是正确的，逻辑上讲这些人肯定已经死了。所以这看起来风险并没有那么大。
They did it methodically, carefully, to avoid making mistakes. But ultimately, they put in fake death dates for all those people. Jeremiah didn't like it, but he did it anyway.
他们有条不紊、小心翼翼地做了这件事，以避免出错。但最终，他们为所有这些人填上了伪造的死亡日期。杰里迈亚不喜欢这样，但他还是照做了。
This fixation with the Death Master File, little did Jeremiah know it was just beginning. A few weeks after the 150-year-olds, Jeremiah says his higher-ups contacted him with a request from DHS, the Department of Homeland Security. And this request was unlike anything Jeremiah had seen in his more than 20 years at the agency.
这种对死亡主文件的执着，杰里迈亚没料到这仅仅是个开始。在150岁的老人名单事件几周后，杰里迈亚说他的上级联系了他，传达了来自国土安全部（DHS）的请求。这个请求与杰里迈亚在局里工作20多年来见过的任何事情都不同。
I got a request from the Deputy Commissioner for Operations, my boss, and said, we have a listing of a little over 6,000 people. You need to come up with a strategy on how we're going to kill off these 6,000 folks, a listing we had received from DHS.
我接到了负责运营的副局长的请求，我的老板说：“我们有一份名单，大概有6000多人。你需要想出一个策略，关于我们如何处理掉这6000个人，这是一份我们从国土安全部收到的名单。”
Kill off? Like--
处理掉？就像——
Yeah, DHS had sent us a list. And the expectation was is that we add a date of death for these individuals.
是的，国土安全部发给了我们一份名单。预期的结果就是我们为这些个人添加一个死亡日期。
To add these 6,000 or so names to the Death Master File. It was strange because, normally, deaths are reported by funeral homes or family members or some state authority. And also, there was no indication from DHS that these people were dead. They just said, add these people to this list. So Jeremiah and his colleagues were trying to figure out, what's going on, and why these 6,000 in particular?
把这6000人左右的名字添加到死亡主文件中。这很奇怪，因为通常情况下，死亡是由殡仪馆、家庭成员或某些州当局上报的。而且，国土安全部没有任何迹象表明这些人已经死亡。他们只是说，把这些人加到这份名单上。所以杰里迈亚和他的同事们试图弄明白，到底发生了什么，为什么偏偏是这6000人？
Like, oh, is a pattern here? Is it all people from one area of the country? There was nothing like that that you were able to see.
就像，这有什么规律吗？他们都是来自全国同一个地区的人吗？你看到过类似的情况吗？
I did not see it. But there were conversations that happened. And the conversations that happened around the agency indicated that it was mostly Hispanic last names.
我没看到。但确实发生过一些谈话。在局里流传的谈话显示，他们大多是西班牙裔的姓氏。
DHS also sent a memo from then-Secretary of Homeland Security, Kristi Noem, about, quote, "suspected terrorists" who she said had Social Security numbers and access to our financial system. She asked the SSA to stop it in a way that was, quote, "consistent with law." Jeremiah was pretty sure none of this request to mark 6,000 people as dead was lawful. No proof of death, for one thing. So he says, he goes and asks someone at the Social Security office of General Counsel, the lawyers, who tell him, yes, it is illegal.
国土安全部还发来了一份时任国土安全部部长克里斯蒂·诺姆（Kristi Noem）的备忘录，关于所谓的“涉嫌恐怖分子”，她说这些人拥有社会保障号码并能进入我们的金融系统。她要求社会保障局以一种“符合法律”的方式阻止他们。杰里迈亚非常确定，这个标记6000人死亡的请求完全不合法。首先，就没有死亡证明。所以他说，他去问了社会保障局总法律顾问办公室的律师，律师告诉他，是的，这是非法的。
The illegal part of it is is making them all dead. You can't just make anybody dead that's not dead. That's against the law.
违法的部分在于把他们都标记为死亡。你不能仅仅因为一个人没死就把他弄死。那是违反法律的。
So Jeremiah and his team refuse. But then, within a couple of days, they start getting some strange reports from the field offices, workers calling in saying, what's going on? People are showing up here saying we marked them as dead. They're definitely not dead.
所以杰里迈亚和他的团队拒绝了。但在几天之内，他们开始收到来自各地方办事处的一些奇怪报告，工作人员打来电话说：“发生了什么事？人们来这里说我们把他们标记为死亡了。他们绝对没有死。”
I'm like, did somebody process these 6,000 deaths? And we started to ask around the agency at headquarters, and we found out that there was staff in the Office of Chief Information Officer that had posted the dates of death.
我当时说：“有人处理了这6000人的死亡案例吗？”我们开始在总部向局里打听，我们发现首席信息官办公室的工作人员已经填上了死亡日期。
He knew the Chief Information Officer staff did it because that was the only office that could process these deaths the way they were processed, all at once. Jeremiah says all 6,000-some people had been marked as having died on a single day, March 8, 2025. He couldn't believe they had done this.
他知道是首席信息官办公室的人干的，因为只有那个办公室能以这种方式一次性处理这些死亡案件。杰里迈亚说这6000多人的死亡日期都被统一标记为2025年3月8日。他不敢相信他们竟然真的这么做了。
I mean, by the agency choosing to do this, we just took a list without any documentation, and we posted these 6,000 deaths. That could have happened to anybody. And within 48 hours, that anybody would have had their lives halted until they could fix it. And it's possible they could fix it in a few days. Or there's been cases where we've seen where it takes months or even a year to fix all of the little things that get screwed up because you got your name on the Death Master File.
我的意思是，由于局里选择这样做，我们接受了一份没有任何文件的名单，并公布了这6000人的死亡。这种事可能发生在任何人身上。在48小时内，那个人的生活就会陷入停滞，直到他们能解决这个问题。他们可能几天内就能解决。或者我们也见过需要几个月甚至一年才能解决所有因名字被列入死亡主文件而搞砸的琐事的案例。
The process of getting resurrected-- that's what they call it when you're accidentally killed in the Death Master File and need to be brought back to life-- it's not simple. You have to go into your Social Security office in person and prove you're alive. And sometimes it takes multiple visits, as you keep encountering new corners of your life where some institution or other is still convinced you're dead.
所谓“复活”的过程——当你在死亡主文件中被意外弄死并需要被带回“生命”时，他们是这样称呼的——并不简单。你必须亲自去社会保障局办公室证明你还活着。有时需要多次访问，因为你会不断遇到生活中的新角落，那里的一些机构仍然坚信你已经死了。
Jeremiah doesn't tell the field offices that the 6,000 or so were secretly killed by the Chief Information Officer's office, or that DHS requested it. He's like, let's not dwell on the mess. Let's just fix it. And let's fix it the way we normally would, as any other mistake in the Death Master File. Which meant it was up to each one of these 6,000 or so people to come into their local field office and prove they're alive.
杰里迈亚没有告诉地方办事处，这6000人左右是被首席信息官办公室秘密弄死的，或者这是国土安全部的要求。他心想，我们别深究这团乱麻了。我们直接修复它吧。而且我们要像处理死亡主文件中的任何其他错误一样，以正常的方式修复它。这意味着这6000多个人中的每一个人都必须亲自前往当地办事处，证明他们还活着。
We saw 30 resurrections happen pretty quickly. And then that number quickly grew within a few weeks to 300 resurrections.
我们很快看到了30次“复活”。然后在几周内，这个数字很快增加到了300次。
So that's what was happening on the ground. Meanwhile, from above--
这就是地面上正在发生的事情。同时，从高层——
We were getting pressure to say, we told you to kill off the 6,000. We want the 6,000 to remain dead.
我们受到了压力，要求说：“我们告诉过你们处理掉这6000人。我们希望这6000人保持死亡状态。”
DHS was telling you that they wanted the 6,000 to remain dead.
国土安全部告诉你他们希望这6000人保持死亡状态？
That's right. And it was coming down from pretty high up leadership.
没错。而且这是从非常高层的领导那里传达下来的。
When these 6,000 fake deaths happened, The Washington Post found out and published a big story. So did The New York Times. So as the news breaks, Jeremiah is also dealing with the chaotic media fallout of this. And then something bigger happens. And this part of the story has not been out there before. Jeremiah is the first person to talk about it.
当这6000起伪造的死亡事件发生时，《华盛顿邮报》发现了并发表了一篇大报道。《纽约时报》也是。所以当新闻爆发时，杰里迈亚也在处理这件事带来的混乱媒体舆论。然后发生了一件更大的事。故事的这一部分以前从未曝光过。杰里迈亚是第一个谈论这件事的人。
So then fast forward a few weeks, and a new request comes in to kill off a new grouping of people. The new request from DHS is for 2.7 million names.
快进几周，出现了一个新的处理人员的请求。来自国土安全部的新请求是270万人。
DHS wants the SSA to kill off 2.7 million people, like an entire city, mark them all as dead in the Death Master File. Again, like last time, no sign or pretense that they're for real dead. DHS tells Jeremiah's team that these 2.7 million are here illegally, and also--
国土安全部希望社会保障局处理掉270万人，就像一个整座城市，在死亡主文件中把他们全部标记为死亡。同样，像上次一样，没有任何迹象或借口证明他们真的死了。国土安全部告诉杰里迈亚的团队，这270万人是非法滞留在这里的，而且——
These folks were violent criminals and suspected terrorists.
这些人是暴力犯罪分子和涉嫌恐怖分子。
But, wait, they told you there were 2.7 million violent criminals and terrorists? That's a lot of violent criminals and suspected terrorists.
但是，等等，他们告诉你有270万名暴力犯罪分子和恐怖分子？那是很多暴力犯罪分子和涉嫌恐怖分子啊。
It is. We were pretty suspect about this 2.7 million list. And so when it came in, we also thought it was a pretty big number. And we wondered whether or not the list was accurate.
确实是。我们对这份270万人的名单感到非常怀疑。所以当它送来时，我们也觉得这是一个非常大的数字。我们怀疑这份名单是否准确。
Last time this happened, when Jeremiah said, wait a minute, these people are alive, that didn't stop the SSA from marking them as dead. So this time he tries something different. He decides to fact check the claims DHS made about the 2.7 million. They can't look at all 2.7 million people. Privacy concerns, and also, the number is so large. But they do get permission to look at a random sample from the list, 25 people. They check what they can.
上次发生这种情况时，当杰里迈亚说：“等一下，这些人还活着”，但这并没有阻止社会保障局将他们标记为死亡。所以这次他尝试了不同的方法。他决定核实国土安全部关于这270万人的说法。他们无法调查所有270万人。隐私问题，而且人数太多。但他们确实获得了查看名单中随机样本的许可，也就是25个人。他们检查了力所能及的内容。
And so we went through to check one, are they dead? Two, are they here legally or not legally? And what is their current status?
所以我们去检查：第一，他们死了吗？第二，他们是合法还是不合法在这里的？他们的现状如何？
When Jeremiah's team ran the numbers, they found that all 25 from the sample were alive. And what's more--
当杰里迈亚的团队运行这些数字时，他们发现样本中的所有25个人都还活着。而且更重要的是——
When we went through the 25 records, we found 23 of them were records where people were either US citizens or lawful permanent resident or were here legally. And then there were two that more investigation needed to occur because it appeared as though that their alien status had expired.
当我们查阅这25条记录时，我们发现其中23个人的记录显示这些人要么是美国公民，要么是合法的永久居民，要么是合法在这里的。还有两个案例需要进一步调查，因为看起来他们的外国人身份已经过期了。
So, alive. And also, most of them clearly in the country legally. Here's what else he remembers from the sample.
所以，他们都活着。而且他们中的大多数显然是合法居住在国家的。这是他从样本中记得的其他事情。
But I do remember that it did span a pretty big age community. So it was children all the way up to people in their 70s. There's a couple of cases that I remember that we just thought were super curious. There were some teenagers on the list. And we're like, OK, so teenagers are suspected terrorists and violent criminals? I mean, I guess that could happen, but the likelihood of it happening didn't make sense.
但我确实记得它涵盖了非常广泛的年龄群体。所以有孩子，一直到70多岁的人。我记得有几个案例，我们觉得非常奇怪。名单上有一些青少年。我们心想，好吧，所以青少年也是涉嫌恐怖分子和暴力犯罪分子？我的意思是，那可能会发生，但发生的可能性让人觉得没道理。
And then there was another person on the list that was a person that had been in the United States for over 50 years and was receiving widow benefits. And we're like, OK, so this person's a violent criminal and a suspected terrorist?
还有名单上的另一个人，是一个在美国待了50多年并领取遗属福利的人。我们心想，好吧，所以这个人也是暴力犯罪分子和涉嫌恐怖分子？
So Jeremiah is like, one, I can't mark people who are alive as dead. Two, they told us these were all people without status, and that seems to not be true. And three, the data I did see from the list makes me side-eye that they're even criminals. Too many red flags in a row. He decides to sound the alarm.
所以杰里迈亚想：第一，我不能把活着的人标记为死亡。第二，他们告诉我们这些人都没有合法身份，这似乎不是真的。第三，我从名单上看到的数据让我怀疑他们是否真的是罪犯。红旗信号太多了。他决定敲响警钟。
I went to my boss. And my boss at the time was now Stephen Evangelista. He had taken over after my other boss left the agency. And I said, we need to have a meeting with DHS. And we need to talk through a couple of things because we think their list is inaccurate. And that's probably a light way of saying that.
我去找了我的老板。当时我的老板是斯蒂芬·埃文杰利斯塔（Stephen Evangelista）。他在我上一任老板离开局里后接手了。我说：“我们需要和国土安全部开个会。我们需要讨论几件事，因为我们认为他们的名单不准确。”这可能还是比较轻描淡写的说法。
So he calls this meeting. They get DHS on a video call. And on the call, Jeremiah says they present their findings, that the people on the list are alive and seem to be here legally. DHS is like, OK, we'll get you a new list. But Jeremiah has another question. "Logistically," he asks, "if there are mistakes on this or any other list you give us, how would a person on the list by mistake fix it?"
于是他安排了这次会议。他们通过视频通话联系了国土安全部。在通话中，杰里迈亚说他们展示了他们的调查结果，即名单上的人还活着，且看起来是合法居住在这里的。国土安全部说：“好吧，我们会给你们一份新名单。”但杰里迈亚还有另一个问题。“从逻辑上讲，”他问，“如果这份名单或你们给我们的任何其他名单上有错误，名单上的人该如何修正？”
And Jon Koval, a DOGE guy at DHS, says, "They would go in person to an SSA office, same as any other mistake. Oh, but when they get there, just flag them over for ICE." Jeremiah says he looked at his coworker, and they were visibly really uncomfortable. ICE is not a place where immigrants who have a mistake on any kind of government papers go to get them straightened out. It's where they go get deported. Jeremiah looks at his boss, Stephen Evangelista. To Jeremiah, DHS's intention is now crystal clear.
国土安全部DOGE的一名成员乔恩·科瓦尔（Jon Koval）说：“他们会亲自去社会保障局办事处，和其他错误一样。噢，但当他们到达那里时，直接把他们标记为移交给移民及海关执法局（ICE）。”杰里迈亚说他看了看他的同事，他们明显非常不安。移民及海关执法局可不是移民在政府文件中出现错误时去寻求纠正的地方。那是他们被驱逐出境的地方。杰里迈亚看向他的老板斯蒂芬·埃文杰利斯塔。对杰里迈亚来说，国土安全部的意图现在清晰明了了。
And so we were like, OK, thank you for the information. We wrapped up the call. Then we're still in the room. And I look across the table. I remember sitting across the table from Stephen. And I said, "The reason that they're doing this with this 2.7 million is because they're trying to deport all of these people. It's plain and obvious." And Stephen said, "You don't know that. You can't be sure of it. That's too much conjecture. You don't know this definitively."
于是我们说：“好吧，感谢提供信息。”我们结束了通话。然后我们仍然坐在会议室里。我记得坐在斯蒂芬对面。我说：“他们用这270万人做这件事的原因，是因为他们试图驱逐所有人。这显而易见。”斯蒂芬说：“你不知道那回事。你不能肯定。那太过推测了。你不能确切地知道这一点。”
And I'm like, "Come on. We know this. This is why this is happening." He's like, "You just don't know it." So we got into a little back-and-forth in reference to that. And he's like, "OK, how about I just call Jon, and I'll ask him?"
我当时说：“别闹了。我们知道。这就是这件事发生的原因。”他说：“你就是不知道。”所以我们就此展开了一些争论。他说：“好吧，我直接给乔恩打个电话问问他怎么样？”
Jon Koval, the DOGE guy working with DHS.
乔恩·科瓦尔，与国土安全部合作的DOGE成员。
I'm like, "OK." He's like, "I'm going to call Jon. You guys be quiet." So "you guys" were me and his technical assistant. And, "I'll just have a quick conversation with Jon in reference to this 2.7 million and why." So he pulls out his cell phone, and he calls Jon. He puts Jon on speakerphone. And he says, Jon, can you tell me why we're going through all this effort with these 2.7 million people?
我说：“好。”他说：“我要给乔恩打电话。你们别出声。”所以“你们”是指我和他的技术助理。“我就关于这270万人以及原因和乔恩进行一次简短的谈话。”于是他拿出手机，拨打了乔恩的电话。他开了免提。他说：“乔恩，你能告诉我我们为什么要在这270万人身上费这么大劲吗？”
And Jon said matter of fact terms back. He's like, "Well, there's two outcomes that we're hoping for here. One, we'll make the people's lives so miserable with-- their lives will just be hard to go through because we'll turn off their credit. We'll turn off their credit card. We'll turn off their bank. They'll just want to self-deport. Or two, they'll go into a Social Security office, and we'll have ICE pick them up there. Or you'll refer them over to us, and ICE will pick them up either at USCIS or at ICE, wherever you determine that they should go." Just matter-of-factly.
乔恩直截了当地回答：“嗯，我们希望有两种结果。第一，我们会让这些人的生活变得极其悲惨——我们会关闭他们的信用，关闭他们的信用卡。我们会关闭他们的银行。他们会想要自己离开。或者第二，他们会去社会保障局办事处，我们会让ICE去那里把他们带走。或者你们把他们转交给我们需要求，ICE会在美国公民及移民服务局或ICE把他们带走，由你们决定把他们送到哪里。”他说得理所当然。
And when he said that, I was shocked that he said it so matter-of-factly. I was pretty shocked that that happened. It's one thing to think you know and be like 98% sure, but you don't really know something. It's different when you know it 100% and you just heard it from a chief official over at DHS who also happens to be a DOGE associate. And he made it very plainly clear that this is what he was trying to do and the outcomes that they were seeking.
当他说出那些话时，我非常震惊，他居然说得那么理所当然。我对他居然真的这么说感到相当震惊。你以为你知道并有98%的把握是一回事，但你并不真的确定。而当你100%确定，且你是从国土安全部的一位高级官员口中听到这些，而他碰巧还是DOGE的成员时，情况就完全不同了。他非常直白地表达了他试图做什么以及他们追求的结果。
Stephen was like, thank you for the information, quickly got off the call. My office, I had to go through a different door than Stephen did, out the conference room. He quickly got up. We didn't talk about it. We didn't have an after-the-meeting conversation about it. That was also a little bit shocking because I'm sure my face said, I told you so, in unequivocal terms. And so he got up. He went to his office. I got up, went to mine. And we never talked about it again.
斯蒂芬说：“谢谢提供信息”，然后迅速结束了通话。我不得不从另一扇门走出会议室，而不是斯蒂芬走的那扇。他迅速站起身。我们没有谈论这件事。会议结束后我们没有进行交流。这也有点令人震惊，因为我相信我的表情已经毫无疑问地表达了“我告诉过你了吧”。他站起身，回到了他的办公室。我站起来，回到了我的办公室。我们再也没有谈论过这件事。
Jeremiah quit the SSA few months later, and now he's filing a whistleblower complaint. The 2.7 million person list was a crisis averted. The SSA didn't add those names to the Death Master File. As far as Jeremiah can tell, they're still alive. But of course, they always were.
杰里迈亚几个月后辞职了，现在他正在提交举报人投诉。这270万人的名单是一场被规避的危机。社会保障局没有把那些名字加进死亡主文件。就杰里迈亚所知，他们仍然活着。当然，他们一直都活着。
The government is filled with things like the Death Master File, built for one purpose, but if you're of a certain disposition, usable for something else. A list of the dead, a public service to track who is alive and who is dead, or a tool to kill off anyone you don't like. It's not legal. It flies in the face of rules and laws that have governed the list for decades. It violates the whole name of the list. But that doesn't mean you can't do it anyway.
政府充斥着像死亡主文件这样的东西，为了一个目的而建立，但如果你有某种倾向，它就能被用于其他用途。一份死者名单，一个追踪谁活着谁死了的公共服务工具，或者一个用来除掉任何你不喜欢的人的工具。这不合法。它违背了数十年来管理该名单的规则和法律。它违反了名单名称的全部意义。但这并不意味着你不能照样做。
Nadia Reiman is a producer on our show. By the way, we did reach out to all the people and agencies Jeremiah names in this story. Only the Department of Homeland Security got back to us. They gave us a statement saying, quote, "The government is finally doing what it should have all along, sharing information across the federal government to solve problems." Two congressional offices are currently looking into the allegations Jeremiah made in his whistleblower claim.
纳迪亚·雷曼是我们节目的制作人。顺便说一下，我们联系了杰里迈亚在这个故事中提到的所有个人和机构。只有国土安全部给了我们回复。他们发表声明说：“政府终于在做它一直应该做的事情，在联邦政府内部共享信息以解决问题。”两个国会办公室目前正在调查杰里迈亚在举报人投诉中提出的指控。
Coming up, one man will suffer through many ordeals to have a private encounter with a God living here on Earth, specifically in Barcelona. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个人将遭受许多磨难，只为与住在这里的一个神灵进行一次私人接触，具体是在巴塞罗那。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ike Sriskandarajah. Today's show, Not Today, Hades. Our last act, Act 3, Zeus. He has taken many forms here on Earth. For the last 20 years, millions have been worshipping a man they say performs miracles. They call him many names-- Magician, Messiah, The Chosen One. And he looks, in some ways, kind of anonymous, like nobody special. He's short, 5' 7". He's soft spoken, shy even. The legends about this man are many. But very few of his devotees have ever actually met him, let alone talked with him.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾。今天的节目，“今天不行，哈迪斯”。最后一幕，宙斯。他曾以多种形式出现在地球上。在过去的20年里，数百万人一直在崇拜一个人，他们说他创造了奇迹。他们叫他很多名字——魔术师、弥赛亚、天选之子。他在某些方面看起来很普通，就像什么特别的人都不是。他很矮，5英尺7英寸（约1.7米）。他说话声音很轻，甚至有些害羞。关于这个人的传奇有很多。但很少有他的信徒真正见过他，更不用说和他说过话了。
Writer Daniel Alarcón is one of them, one of the very few mere mortals to have met Lionel Messi, arguably the greatest soccer player of all time. Daniel talked about it on the podcast he hosts with his longtime friend, who's also a writer, John Green. Daniel adapted it for our show.
作家丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔（Daniel Alarcón）就是其中之一，是极少数见过莱昂内尔·梅西（Lionel Messi）的凡人之一，梅西可以说是有史以来最伟大的足球运动员。丹尼尔在他与多年好友、同样也是作家的约翰·格林（John Green）共同主持的播客中谈到了这件事。丹尼尔为我们的节目改编了内容。
So John, once upon a time, there were many, many magazines that were published in the United States and around the world. As you know, I've written for many of them. And magazines, for our younger listeners, are very thin little books.
所以约翰，很久以前，美国和世界各地出版了许多许多杂志。如你所知，我为其中很多杂志写过稿。对于我们年轻的听众来说，杂志是非常薄的小书。
It's like Instagram, but text-based and printed.
就像Instagram，但基于文字且被打印出来。
Yes. And there was a specific niche among these that were called glossies. And glossies were the high-end fashion magazines. And the glossies got their name from the glossy paper that they were printed on. So Vanity Fair, GQ, Vogue, those are the glossies. And they were kind of lucrative.
是的。其中有一个特殊的细分领域被称为“光面杂志”（Glossies）。光面杂志是高端时尚杂志。它们的名字来源于打印它们时所用的光面纸。所以《名利场》、《GQ》、《Vogue》就是光面杂志。它们当时相当有利可图。
Yeah, they paid great.
是的，报酬很高。
They paid so much money. I had never written for a glossy magazine, I should say, until one of these editors who worked at one of these magazines called me up and asked me if I was interested in writing a profile of Lionel Messi. And of course, I was interested, huge soccer fan, blah blah blah. The problem is that I was about to be married, and the reporting trip would be the week after my wedding.
它们付了很多钱。我应该说，在这些杂志的一位编辑打电话给我，问我是否有兴趣为莱昂内尔·梅西写人物专访之前，我从未为光面杂志写过稿。当然，我有兴趣，我是个巨大的足球迷，等等等等。问题在于我当时快要结婚了，而报道旅行定在我婚礼后的一周。
So terrible timing. I was told I would get to spend three days with the world's greatest player. I'd get to see a training session. I'd get to go to a game. I'd have full access. And I spoke with Carolina. And she said, you've got to go, you got to do this, and we would do the honeymoon later. And I think you know this, but I think it's worth repeating, just what a genius Lionel Messi is, spoken of in the same breath as Pelé, as Maradona.
时机真是太糟糕了。我被告知我将有三天时间与世界上最伟大的球员在一起。我可以看一场训练，可以去看一场比赛。我有完全的访问权。我和卡罗琳娜（Carolina）谈过。她说：“你必须去，你得去完成这个，我们以后再去度蜜月。”我想你明白这一点，但我认为值得重申，莱昂内尔·梅西是多么天才，他被与贝利（Pelé）和马拉多纳（Maradona）相提并论。
And I felt like there are people who watch Lionel Messi play a game, and they're like, man, he's good. And there are people like me, who understand it or feel like we understand it on a completely different level. And I thought that there would be a way that I could express to him that my understanding of what he was accomplishing on the pitch was not like, woo hoo, goal. You know? It was a much more sophisticated understanding. And I was like, yeah, no doubt, me and Leo are going to be friends.
我觉得有人看莱昂内尔·梅西比赛时会说：“天哪，他真棒。”而像我这样的人，完全能在另一个层面上理解它或感觉自己理解它。我以为我能向他表达我对他球场上成就的理解不是像那种“呜呼，进球了”。你明白吗？那是更深层次的理解。我当时想，没错，毫无疑问，我和里奥（Leo）会成为朋友的。
That's totally realistic.
那真是太现实了。
I was imagining us hanging out at his house, playing Xbox or FIFA or something, and then going to eat some Argentine barbecue somewhere, the grill in Barcelona somewhere, and then riding in his car. And then at the end of the night he'd be like, you know what, man? You're so cool. Cancel your flight back. We're hanging out.
我当时想象着我们在他家聚会，玩Xbox或FIFA之类的，然后去某处吃些阿根廷烤肉，巴塞罗那的某家烤肉店，然后坐他的车。晚上结束时他会说：“你知道吗，伙计？你太酷了。取消你的返程机票吧。我们再聚聚。”
Yeah.
是的。
Normal stuff. So this is what I was imagining. And, yeah, so basically, 36 hours after my wedding, I'm on a plane to Barcelona. I arrived at New York. So I flew from San Francisco to New York. I checked my email. And that's when I got the first blow, which was that I would no longer have three days with Lionel Messi. I would have a single day.
很正常的事。所以这就是我当时想象的。是的，所以基本上，我婚礼后36小时，我就坐上了去巴塞罗那的飞机。我到了纽约。所以我从旧金山飞往纽约。我检查了邮件。那是我遭遇的第一次打击，那就是我将不再拥有三天时间与莱昂内尔·梅西在一起。我只有一天。
Now, I still thought a single day is good. I was like, a day. That's still pretty good. I checked my email again when I got to Barcelona, and now it was no longer a day. It was an hour. So at this point, just to be clear, I had given up my honeymoon to spend an hour with a soccer player. It was just beginning to dawn on me that this was the wrong way to start my marriage, right?
现在，我仍然认为一天也不错。我当时心想，一天。那还是很不错的。我到巴塞罗那后又检查了邮件，现在连一天也没有了。只有一个小时。此时，为了清楚起见，我已经放弃了蜜月去和一个足球运动员待一小时。我开始意识到这是开始我婚姻的错误方式，对吧？
So here's what happened. I got to Barcelona. I had planned four days in town. Now I've got two extra days to report. So I'm just going to report the [BLEEP] out of this story, which is what I do. So I talked to everybody. I found the guy who took Messi's first photo ID back when Messi was a teenager with long hair and he needed his ID card so he could enter the grounds of the stadium. I found the owners of the Argentine restaurant in the suburb where Messi has his gigantic home. And I got to sit in the booth where Messi sometimes goes to eat.
所以发生了什么。我到了巴塞罗那。我计划在城里待四天。现在我有两天额外的时间来报道。所以我就要全力去报道这个故事，这是我擅长的。所以我采访了所有人。我找到了当年梅西还是长发青少年时为他拍第一张身份证照片的那个人，当时他需要身份证才能进入体育场。我找到了梅西那座巨大豪宅所在的郊区的一家阿根廷餐馆的老板。我还坐在了梅西有时去吃饭的卡座里。
So anyway, I finally do have my day where I'm going to go meet Lionel Messi. And I'm told to get to the Cuitat Esportiva around 10:00 AM. And of course, I did. Punctually there.
不管怎样，我终于等到了我要去见莱昂内尔·梅西的那一天。我被告知上午10点左右到达体育城（Ciutat Esportiva）。当然，我准时到了。
And I get there, and I'm like, hey, so I'm a journalist for this fancy glossy magazine. This was all been scheduled. Publicists, editors have been negotiating my arrival. Can I walk around? No, no. No, you can't. I'm like, OK. And they take me to this kind of press room. And they tell me Messi will be there in a few minutes.
我到了那里，说：“嘿，我是这本高级时尚杂志的记者。这一切都已经安排好了。公关人员、编辑都在协商我的到来。我能到处转转吗？”“不，不。不行，你不能。”我心想，好吧。他们把我带到这个像是新闻发布室的地方。他们告诉我梅西几分钟内就会到。
It's super hot. This is like September. I was not given so much as a glass of water. And I waited, and I waited, and I waited. And then someone came in and told me that I'd be meeting Messi actually, not then, but before afternoon training. And I was like, OK. So can I watch the training? And they're like, no, absolutely not. You cannot watch the training. And I'm just like, what the hell? I'm like, what is this?
那里热得要命。现在是九月。他们连一杯水都没给我。我等啊，等啊，等啊。然后有人进来告诉我，实际上我会见梅西不是那时候，而是在下午训练之前。我心想，好吧。那我能观看训练吗？他们说：“不，绝对不行。你不能看训练。”我当时只想，这到底是什么鬼？心想，这是怎么回事？
So I kind of like am peeking out the window. And I see Messi and the other players arrive. They have super fancy cars. And naturally, Messi did not come up to speak to me before training. And a little factotum was sent up to tell me that he would come after training. So at this point, training started at 3:00. I've been there, remember, since 10:00.
所以我有点从窗户往外窥探。我看到梅西和其他球员到了。他们开着超级豪华的车。当然，梅西在训练前并没有上来跟我说话。一个小随从被派上来说他训练后会过来。所以此时，训练是3点开始。记住，我从10点就在那里了。
I've resorted to going to the bathroom and just lapping water into my mouth out of the sink because I have not been given anything. That's nothing. I'm eating wadded up paper towels, just chewing on paper just to trick myself. I'm starving. And then I didn't know what had happened at training that day. I found out later. But I could tell, because I am an astute judge of character, John, as you know, that something bad had happened at training.
我不得不去洗手间，从洗手池里往嘴里舀水喝，因为我什么也没得到。这根本不算什么。我甚至在吃揉成团的纸巾，只是嚼纸来欺骗自己。我快饿死了。然后我当时不知道那天训练发生了什么。我是后来才知道的。但我看得出来，因为正如你所知，约翰，我是个敏锐的性格判断者，那天训练中发生了糟糕的事情。
I kind of saw the players trudging off with this look of "there but for the grace of God go I." They had seen something. I found out later that the something they had seen was a young player named Ibrahim Afellay had torn his ACL. And so I, of course, was not allowed to watch training. So I didn't see any of this. But I could sense something was wrong.
我看到球员们拖着沉重的步伐走出来，脸上带着“多亏了上帝，没发生在我身上”的表情。他们看到了一些事情。后来我才知道他们看到的事情是一名年轻球员叫易卜拉欣·阿费莱（Ibrahim Afellay）撕裂了前十字韧带。所以当然，我不被允许观看训练。所以我没看到这一切。但我能感觉到出了问题。
And that is one of those things that I think really affects players' moods because they know that all of them are one bad turn, one injury like that, away from sitting out for a year. You know? And maybe, like in the case of Ibrahim Afellay--
这就是我认为真正影响球员心情的事情之一，因为他们知道他们所有人离坐板凳一年都只有一次坏的转身，一次像那样的伤病距离。你明白吗？也许就像易卜拉欣·阿费莱那样——
And maybe never quite being the same.
也许永远无法完全恢复到原来的状态。
Never quite being the same, exactly, which is precisely what happened to Afellay.
完全无法恢复如初，正是这样，这正是发生在阿费莱身上的事情。
Anyway, at this point, it's past 6:00 PM. So I've been there for a full working day, nothing to eat, super hot. And I'm not one to be dramatic, John, but I was basically being held prisoner at the Barcelona training ground by that point. That's how it felt.
总之，此时已经过了下午6点。我已经在那里待了完整的一个工作日，什么都没吃，热得要命。约翰，我不是那种夸张的人，但到那时为止，我基本上就是被关在巴塞罗那训练基地的囚犯。感觉就是那样。
So finally, it's just before 7:00 PM when the world's greatest player finally walks in. We sit down at this table. It's this little silver table. There's three chairs. It's me across from Messi. And his publicist is kind of in the middle. And so begins the world's worst interview. [LAUGHTER] It's like, he batted me away like-- I can't remember what I asked him, but he gave me this look like he'd rather be at the dentist.
终于，在下午7点前，世界上最伟大的球员终于进来了。我们坐在这张桌子旁。那是一张银色的小桌子。有三把椅子。我和梅西相对而坐。他的公关人员坐在中间。于是世界上最糟糕的采访开始了。（笑声）他把我拒之门外，就像——我不记得我问了他什么，但他给了我那种他宁愿去看牙医的表情。
And just looking at me, and I'm disheveled and sweaty. My shirt was a normal size at the beginning of the day, but after eight hours of being held hostage at the Barcelona training ground in a hot September day, the shirt was just stuck to me. And I asked my first question. And he said this thing, and I'm going to imitate an Argentine accent. He said--
他就那样看着我，而我衣衫不整，满头大汗。我的衬衫在白天开始时是正常尺寸的，但在九月炎热的一天被当作人质扣押在巴塞罗那训练基地八小时后，衬衫已经粘在我身上了。我问了第一个问题。他说了一句，我要模仿一下阿根廷口音。他说——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
--which Is basically like, dude, I've been asked this so many times. He's rolling his eyes. And I'm just--
——这基本上就像是，伙计，这个问题我被问过太多次了。他翻了个白眼。而我只是——
Oh God.
天哪。
And it got worse from there. It just got worse. I realize that something bad has happened at training. I realize that he's not interested in speaking with me. He doesn't know what a GQ is or what a Vogue is. He doesn't give a [BLEEP]. He doesn't care. He's just like, this weird guy who's all sweaty is sitting here. He's been waiting for me for eight hours, like a freaking stalker. And now he's asking me dumb questions that I've been asked before.
情况从此变得更糟了。变得更糟了。我意识到训练中发生了不好的事情。我意识到他不想跟我说话。他不知道什么是GQ，什么是Vogue。他一点都不在乎。他只是心想，这个浑身是汗的怪人坐在这里。他像个疯狂的跟踪狂一样等了我八个小时。现在他还在问那些我以前就被问过的蠢问题。
And so he's just being monosyllabic. And at the end of it, it's just devastating. Basically, the publicist just kind of calls time on it, and it's done. Before he walks out, we take this photograph. I ask the publicist if it's OK if we take a photograph. And he said this thing to me. He's like, of course. I know we all have feelings.
所以他只是回答单音节词。到最后，这简直是毁灭性的。基本上，公关人员只是宣布时间到了，这就结束了。在他走出去之前，我们拍了那张照片。我问公关人员能不能拍张照。他对我说了那句话。他说：“当然。我知道我们都有感情。”
We all have feelings?
我们都有感情？
The publicist can sense my humiliation, which is actually manifesting as physical pain. Like, at this point, it's just like this is the worst reporting experience of my life, possibly one of the most humiliating experiences of my life at all, of the whole of it. So I took my photo. Messi walks out, immediately, of course, forgets the entire interaction that I have never forgotten.
公关人员能感觉到我的羞辱，这实际上表现为身体上的痛苦。就像，此时此刻这就是我一生中最糟糕的报道经历，可能是我一生中最令我羞辱的经历，整个一生。所以我拍了照。梅西走出去，当然立即就忘记了我从未忘记的整个互动。
Needless to say, I wrote my draft and then got a very efficient, carefully-worded email from my editor saying that the article was not going to be published and that I could kindly take my kill fee and go away.
不用说，我写了初稿，然后收到了一封极其高效、措辞谨慎的编辑来信，说这篇文章将不会出版，我可以客气地拿走我的“杀费”（即不用稿费）然后离开。
Brutal.
残酷。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't know how to ask this delicately, but even on his best day, Lionel Messi is pretty at arms length when it comes to interviews. And in retrospect, there is something charming about the fact that you thought you were going to get the real Lionel Messi.
我不知道该怎么委婉地问，但即使在最好的日子里，莱昂内尔·梅西在接受采访时也相当保持距离。回想起来，你以为你会得到一个真实的莱昂内尔·梅西，这事确实有某种迷人之处。
Yeah. I mean, he batted me aside like I was a third-tier defender and went on with his life. And so here I am thinking, man, we're going to vibe on this because we both have this deep emotional and deep intellectual understanding of the game. And basically what he was telling me was like, no, you're down here, and I'm up here.
是的。我的意思是，他把我像三流后卫一样推到一边，然后继续他的生活。所以我在这里心想，伙计，我们会产生共鸣的，因为我们对这场比赛都有深厚的情感和深刻的理解。而他基本上就是在告诉我：不，你在下面，我在上面。
Daniel and John's show is called The Away End, which is a soccer podcast about the run-up to the World Cup made by two people who really like books. Emmanuel Dzotsi produced this version for our show.
丹尼尔和约翰的节目叫《客场》（The Away End），这是一个关于世界杯前夕的足球播客，由两个真正喜欢书的人制作。伊曼纽尔·佐齐（Emmanuel Dzotsi）为我们的节目制作了这一版本。
Our program was produced today by me and edited by David Kestenbaum. The people who put together today's show are Phia Bennin, Dana Chivvis, Cassie Howley, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Robin Reid, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu.
今天的节目由我和大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）制作和编辑。今天整理节目的人员有菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、凯西·霍利（Cassie Howley）、阿德里安·莉莉（Adriene Lilly）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、莫莉·马塞洛（Molly Marcello）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、罗宾·里德（Robin Reid）、莱恩·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, and our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Very special thanks today to Sam McKiniss. Thanks also to all This American Life partners. When you join, you'll get regular, exclusive bonus episodes, listen ad-free, most importantly, help us continue making this show. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的总编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman），执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。今天特别感谢山姆·麦金尼斯（Sam McKiniss）。也要感谢《美国生活》的所有合作伙伴。当你加入时，你将获得常规的、独家的奖金剧集，享受无广告收听，最重要的是，帮助我们继续制作这个节目。加入地址：thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our boss, Ira Glass. You know, at his own wedding recently, he decided it would be funny to start his vows by saying, "it's This American Wife." Nobody laughed.
一如既往地感谢我们的老板艾拉·格拉斯。你知道，在他最近自己的婚礼上，他决定以说“这是《美国生活》的妻子”来开始他的誓言，这会很有趣。结果没人笑。
It was just beginning to dawn on me that this was the wrong way to start my marriage.
我开始意识到这是开始我婚姻的错误方式。
I'm Ike Sriskandarajah. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾。艾拉·格拉斯下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。